[Music]
all right
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through philosophy behind practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi I'm Dan Hayes I'm joined by my
co-host Dr Greg Sadler and today we're
talking about ethical dimensions of
gambling and we should specify that
we're not talking about just you know
setting up a little blackjack or poker
game among friends or something like
that we're talking about the big
business of gambling and we've been
wanting to talk about this for a little
while on that a news story came along
last week that kind of clinched it for
us you know giving us the needed kick in
the pants to start talking about this
and it's about the local casino the
Potawatomi Casino and Hotel it was in
Milwaukee magazine and the story
um is that they're demolishing the
northern Lights
Theater the the venue and a restaurant
in order to make room for sports book
and so this new venue is going to
replace two different things so here's a
little quote from the article in the
coming weeks and throughout construction
of the sports book venue the casino will
provide guests to location with 17
kiosks between them open 24 hours a day
for the placing of bets one of these
locations will be near the former fire
pit Sports Bar and Grill site here
guests will find a full bar eight high
definition televisions and one large LED
screen to take in the day's biggest
games kiosks will be found off the
Skywalk on the property's second level
both locations will provide odds boards
sports betting guests can also take
advantage of 20-minute dedicated parking
spots in the structure all bets must be
placed on site at and so there's a lot
we could like read in there there's
there's not much discussion of what's
been taken away or what's vanished right
and it's all this essentially almost
like a press release about how great the
the sports book betting is going to be
but one of the things that really caught
my attention about that besides the
20-minute dedicated parking spot so you
can zip in and zip out and make your
bets 24 hours a day
so you know they they clearly uh know
what their
not audience because no longer an
audience the uh the music venues gone
away but they're what should we call
them customers
um oh marks I I was thinking about that
word as well yeah I mean in in Britain
they would call them punters right which
is this sort of catch-all for anybody
who's doing this sort of thing and
applies to a lot of Industries
um what do you what do you make of this
they're definitely you know
they see that Sports gambling is is
expanding and exploding across the
country now
um and they're I guess they're like oh
we we need to like cash in on this but
unfortunately it's at the detriment to
this quite nice uh venue that they're
tearing down
um in its place but I think that the you
know absolutely the 20 minute it's like
definitely facilitating this like hey
we'll make this as easy as possible you
you can pull up real close and just like
run and run out
um as well as you know I guess they're
like okay well
Sports happen all over the world yeah so
you could you know there's all sorts of
uh you know uh football or as we would
call it soccer games that are going on
all around the world there's uh rugby
there's Cricket there's all sorts of
things as if they're like like we want
to be able to get into all of them I
guess it makes sense from like a
financial standpoint
um but the question is like
is this a uh overall positive or
negative thing on on the city on on the
populace in general or is this
this is kind of benign yeah and I think
a lot of people would say well you know
it's a private company let them do
whatever they want with it but you know
that's not really the case for a lot of
gambling let's call them institutions
they're they exist and they've been
allowed to like you know come in and
provide it because there's supposed to
be more than just a bunch of private
transactions going on they're supposed
to be a public good that is provided
this is where we get all sorts of
interesting ethical questions
um you know all of which I think
you know Dan and I are not you know
anti-gambling per se or anything like
that I've I've certainly gone to uh
casinos in the past and played sloths
you know uh up at Oneida for example
when I was a college student and when I
was in the Army uh gambling on post was
uh not regulated because it's all state
right so you know we would go to the uh
I forget what the name of the bar was on
post but we would you know pump money
into the slot machine there and some
people would lose a lot some people
would know when to cut themselves off
um so you know there's there's a lot of
complex questions built into this and I
don't think we have any black and white
either yes or no absolutely sorts of
answers but that's that's why we need
philosophy to dig into this right
so yeah as
um you know I
was taught I had like you know stats in
high school and I was taught
um yeah the probabilities
um from that point and it was like you
know unless you're really good at like
certain table games the the
probabilities over time are always going
to result in you losing that they're the
games are awesome that's right set
against you and so you know I I've
gambled a couple times but I look at it
only as
um at least personally for me as
entertainment and as long as you can I'd
say if you can look at it as an
entertainment and not as a you know a
means to an end of like making sure that
you're like paying your rent or
something yeah that's really problematic
isn't it yeah
um then then you're going to have uh no
problem I guess from me from an
individual ethical position but it does
uh you know there are instances where
um allowing or to to go along this and
spend your money on this is going to be
unethical goal yeah and promoting it in
the way that we do or allowing it to be
promoted
um raises a lot of questions I I
actually was going to mention too though
uh one of the people because you you
brought up probability so one of the
people who made big contributions to the
theory of probability is Blaise Pascal
and why did he do it well he was a
gambler and kind of uh in veteran
Gambler at that early point in his life
and he um you know he wanted to sort of
figure out how to work the odds in his
favor so he had to figure out how to
calculate odds and that's that's what he
did I'll also mention another thing too
so this is sort of like making good out
of bad we wouldn't have Theodore
dostoyevsky's novels most likely if he
wasn't a degenerate Gambler who was
constantly getting himself further and
further into debt and his family into
debt had needed to write frantically in
order to make money to pay off his camp
like debts so he would write these
serialized uh works and so you know we
could we could say well see some good
results come out of it depending on how
you look at dostoyevsky's short stories
and novels whether you think that
they're a good result
so I I think they are
Boone to our literary artistic you know
Treasure Trove that Humanity has yeah uh
he also wants us about gambling too yes
but but like hey look we got like a
couple of really good uh novels and
short stories over here but there's all
these people that have totally destroyed
their lives
yeah you know gambling plays such a big
role in a lot of literature you know
Mark Twain talks about it
um uh the novel Vanity Fair by Thackery
these these various characters go deep
deep deep into debt you know because
they're extended a lot of credit uh we
should come back to the the particular
topic though so you know what's what's
actually going on is something that's
not just about Milwaukee or the
Potawatomi Casino and Hotel there have
been a lot of you could say incremental
increases in gambling I'm old enough to
remember when the Wisconsin Lottery
first came out and was proposed it's
going to like you know fund education
and all of that and we'll talk about
that a little bit down the line it
doesn't quite work like that but there's
been some recent increases and I I first
noticed this when we were watching uh
NFL football games on TV because last
year the advertisements which we only
see advertisements when we're watching
live TV they were all for crypto and
which is you know you could say there's
a speculative element in that as well
right almost entirely yeah now this year
it was all about sports gambling
and so it was like DraftKings and I
forget which other ones and you know
they've got celebrities really
high-powered
um people coming in saying this is fun
you know you'll get some you can start
off and they'll give you some credit I
mean it's a very strong sell right so it
even reminds me of like um
the whole you know you got your drug
dealer and it's like here's here's the
first time
yeah yeah
um because they're like hey I saw like a
commercial recently I was like yo your
first bet is free up to like three
hundred dollars it was like it's totally
on us I was like well I've got nothing
to lose and of course and then they have
you know
um the apps are set up
um and in ways that are very much set to
uh get you to come back all the time
they always have notifications
remind you and they'll give you bonuses
and extra money if you come and like uh
play every day and so they're they're
building habits for you in those apps
just like you know potawatomie and other
casinos will do with their their loyalty
programs right as long as you come in
over and over again they want you to
come in they want you to build that
habit that you're always coming in so
it's not a uh thing to think about it's
like oh that's just what you do on
Friday night or something that's
interesting that you put it that way it
becomes not just a habit it becomes you
could say the environment that you feel
comfortable in yeah right so like with
some people going to the gym you know at
first it feels kind of forward and alien
and then after a while it's it's part of
your routine I I you know I knew a guy
and
I'll just tell you this story super
quick and then let's talk about you know
what what's been going on in recent
history so this was way way back when I
was in college so we're talking about in
the 1990s and we worked security
together and he was living on campus and
every single month he would get his
paycheck and he would drive up to Oneida
and within two days he had lost
everything now fortunately he had his
room covered he had his board covered
you know I'm not sure where he's getting
his gas money from maybe at another job
or something but he was he was you know
within the week he was always asking us
for money and you know a couple people
loaned him money and then they just cut
him off because they realized you know
it was it was a Bad Bet to loan him
anything but back to this so you know
what's changed recently
um it's a sports betting that is
becoming really big so there was this
professional and amateur sports
protection act of 1992. and it defined
the legal status of sports betting
throughout the United States effectively
outlawing sports betting Nationwide and
why because it was a big problem and
nobody was quite sure about how it would
work and there were some exemptions you
know like dog racing and horse racing
and weirdly enough High Ali I'm not
quite sure how that snuck in
um and then in 2018 so very recently the
Supreme Court ruled that the law
violated the 10th Amendment and that the
whole law was unconstitutional so they
throw the whole thing out which means
that everything becomes open and since
then 35 States in Washington DC have
legalized sports betting and it's this
is the most interesting part so all of
these sports leagues were originally
against that sort of gambling because I
think they realized the sort of effects
that it could have even within the
leagues you know I remember Pete Rose
getting in in deep trouble people for
his his gambling way back in the day so
the NBA the NFL the NHL Major League
Baseball and the NCAA originally opposed
legalized betting on games
sense the decision they have changed
their tune they've made it 180 degree
turn and the the four professional
leagues entered into Partnerships with
major sports book operators and now we
see all these broadcasts you know if the
NFL didn't want those ads airing they
wouldn't be airing and I assume it's the
same for NBA and you know Major League
Baseball I don't watch those on TV but
I'm assuming that it's the same sort of
ads and you know there's not a lot of
Regulation going on so it's a wide open
field at this time and I think that's
why our local casino has decided to get
into it yeah it's it's the largest
growth area in uh gambling in the United
States
yeah it's bringing in you know billions
of dollars is a multi-billion dollar
industry
um and it just continues to grow that
makes a lot of sense because all the
established things are going to have a
you know sort of like a regular rate of
return you can expect right so this
would be the place where if you are
operating a gambling establishment
you would want to
um make more money no and and they
they've
um divided it out so much that you can
make you know bets on the smallest
things like you know this particular
player is going to in the first quarter
of this football game is going to make
you know
37 or more yards or something wow those
lines
um or even like a individual series you
can like you can bet on the next like
three plays
um you know they've so divided it's not
like uh like just you're over under on a
whole game by the way yeah yeah like
yeah you can be constantly about in the
entire time the game is going on
um and they've got all the the stats
rolling in and they'll just constantly
churning through those and so that is
that's why they love it yeah
um you and
it's
oh how we say I have like you're trying
to it's not like Medicare huh yeah well
it's not like you're
um the slot machines where
you know the the house can win or not
um because it is uh or the house is
always going to win and if you as long
as you uh over time it's going to loosen
there's all these like odds makers that
are trying to go but like you know
people feel like they have a better idea
of what's going to happen with sports
than just pull on a 11.
yeah so there's there's this uh feeling
that you can more easily beat the house
but they have lots and lots of
statisticians that they pay a lot of
money on yeah figure out what the actual
probabilities are here they're still
going to win
you know we were going to talk about
this later but there is that proverb The
House Always Wins and you know we we did
do a little bit of thinking about that
so let's let's jump into that and then
we'll talk about you know what what
gambling is and the ethics of it so you
know there's this old slogan and it's
more or less right
um the way you could translate it is the
entity that's running or sponsoring the
gambling will always be the winner over
any given period of time in the sense of
making more money and there will be
exceptions there'll be like somebody who
spins the roulette wheel and you know
they happen to have put it on something
and they get a ton of money and then
they walk out of there and that doesn't
that doesn't change it because that's
already factored in to the house winning
so they know that the way the the player
is going to win X amount of times and
they're gonna they're gonna win really
big hit the jackpot this percentage of
times but they know that over you know a
week or a month or a year that the the
overall probability
um because once once you have enough
data points and you have a very you know
everything you know goes to the bell
curve really well
um so for example
um slot machines uh are games of chance
but they're tuned so the probability of
payout is always less than 50 percent
over a given period of time the house
Edge or the gross profits for each one
of these things uh
uh
poker devices are slots
um can fluctuate from
um just say a 0.5 percent uh take to a
40 take for the house so the house is
either winning
50.25 of the time or over 70 percent of
the time wow you know lottery tickets
are kind of great because if you
actually look on the back it will tell
you precisely what the odds are and I
mean the thing that's probably that
drives it home the most it will be where
they say a certain amount is going to
pay off winners and it's not a hundred
percent it's usually a little bit over
50 percent which means that any any
ticket that you buy you know you're
you're odds are you're losing money on
it as an investment and I think a lot of
people look at it as sort of like the
poor man's investment as well
foreign
a lot of the big National lottos you're
more likely to get struck by lightning
than win the lotto yeah that's true
which is kind of like it puts it in
perspective and then also if you want to
like go and play like poker you know the
the uh house still is gonna get their
take which is called the rake and so
every time that you are playing a hand
there's a little bit that goes back to
the house even if you're playing against
like four other guys not in the house
not is not even playing like you're
talking about like um Texas Hold'em and
the dealer isn't playing with you
um they're always going to be taking
their little bit cut and so that's you
know they are built as businesses if you
are uh running a casino and you are
somehow losing money then you have
royally screwed up yeah something's
going wrong you you need to rework your
your stuff and I I kind of think that we
need to expand our conception these days
of what the house is it's not just the
gambling institution or site now it's
really any entity that is powerful in
comparison to The Gambler that are
consistently making money off of it and
that can use that money and use that
power to decide what's legal or not and
determine the culture
um including you know fostering a
culture of addiction so I would say that
you know you know we've got like the the
casinos the companies both the sports
leagues themselves are also you know in
cahoots in this case and media
organizations Disney owns DraftKings or
is in partnership with them and there's
many others and then you know the
governments that are deriving income
from this are usually complicit uh
they're not regulating they're not
checking up on this except in places
like you know say Nevada where they've
got a long history of it I think that
Wisconsin you know
um maybe not not quite as on top of
things as others would be and then when
it comes to these Trans State even
transnational things like gambling
websites I mean how do you regulate them
yeah and and in preparation for the show
like I went and I went to the Nevada
state gambling commission and they put
out monthly reports yeah on every Casino
in the states and it gives you break
down by the casino
um broken down by each individual like
table game as well as each individual
wow
um
uh
why am I losing this word um
pulling the lever are you gesturing
about slot machines yeah slot machines
each individual slots right slot
machines by denomination so like Penny
quarter nickel dollar slots
that you can look at exactly what
they're on their take was what the
probability was for those particular
slotch machines at those particular
gambling establishments yeah it's
amazing the amount of data they provide
um because they have such a long history
of this yeah and so that sort of
transparency is actually quite good you
know and I think we're you know is
anybody doing that for these Myriad
different little micro bets that people
can make where they're not betting on
like an entire game but rather on all of
these tiny components of it I doubt it
you know yeah I'm right there with you
yeah well let's let's talk about ethics
because uh we promised that in the title
we haven't gotten to that yet
um yeah so uh we've got a number of
questions here both from an individual
ethical position as well as like a maybe
a societal ethical position and so
let me guess depending on your ethical
system you might have
um like a
uh not a
categorical
um imperative against uh gambling but
maybe a hypothetical and so what that
means some do some some Outlaw gambling
entirely yeah but but does that not
still a hypothetical based upon if you
agree with a particular ethical system
I see what you're saying yeah so you're
trying you're thinking about this in in
sort of conscient terms
um and yes it would be for those people
who do agree with that particular it's
it's usually not an ethical system as
such
distance from religion it's usually some
sort of religious uh Motif but you know
there have been various denominations
that not only said you shouldn't gamble
but
um frowned on purchasing stocks because
that was viewed as a another type of
gambling right I think a lot of that's
gone away though yeah yeah and I know
specifically the Quakers as a religious
system
um frowns upon uh gambling as well as
stocks just as you said yeah
um and and they're in there are reasons
for doing so are interesting it's not
just like being ascetic and no we
shouldn't have any fun gambling's fun
right yeah they've got I found two
arguments from the uh Quaker perspective
specifically that on
uh many participants will desire greater
winnings valuing Earthly Goods over
spiritual gain than thus this greed
violates the Quaker testimonial of
Simplicity and so this is they have a
very anti-materialist
um ideas within the Quaker tradition and
so the gambling because it's all about
trying to acquire material things
results in on them violating one of
their core tenants and another one is
um that they look at gambling as a
zero-sum game instead of a mutually
supportive Endeavor like you know if you
go to a market and
um I'm not a fisherman but you know Bob
over there is yeah yeah I can I can give
him some bread and he does he's not a
baker so like we're exchanging I'm
getting something more value to me
because I don't fish and he gets
something that he doesn't get uh because
he's not a baker yeah I mean the only
way that you could say that gambling is
producing a surplus would be to talk
about like so we use this word
entertainment earlier and that's a
that's a really key buzzword that
gambling proponents will use in kind of
a cya format or or Motif but you could
say well if you're if everybody's having
a good time then
um there's some Surplus created but I
don't think that's really the case
because you when you look at gamblers
when they start to lose they're
miserable and angry and so maybe the
zero-sumthing
really does hold you know
yeah even with respect to affects yeah I
was gonna say like the whole um
everyone's having a good time doesn't
mean that it's a good thing that you do
and even though everyone's having a good
time like I'm thinking like what is it
opium dens it's like everyone's like oh
yeah they gotta get the opium everyone's
in there it's like yeah this is great
um yeah yeah not not actually good for
you uh long term or probably short well
for my limited exposure
um you know playing games not just in
casinos but like you know playing poker
or stuff like that when people start to
lose they're not having a good time they
start to they start to get angry they
start to get desperate they're like I'm
gonna you know let's double or nothing
and then you're like are you sure about
that yeah yeah let's do it you know and
so oh well and I saw a lot of people
when I was in the Army who who lost lots
of money and boy were they upset after
that you know
so yeah go ahead
so
is is playing a game of chance in which
there's nothing seriously playing poker
but there's like you're not actually
playing with money is that just a game
or is that still a little bit of
gambling
it kind of depends are are you are you
just like totaling up points like
illusory
credits or something like that I guess
that and it's not really gambling right
unless you can trade those for something
yeah
yeah like um
in Star Trek TNT yeah
um the bridge crew has a long-standing
poker game right and sometimes they'll
they'll they'll because it's it's a post
scarcity Society it doesn't matter but
but sometimes they'll get the other
people to do things that they might not
want to do on for winning or losing okay
and so there is something that's being
given up but no longer is it monetary or
materialistic because all of those needs
are already met so there is something
that you can bet but it's not monetary
it's more in terms of like Prestige or
power or favors yeah yeah yeah I mean
you could Define power as the as being
able to get people to do things right so
yeah uh if I if you owe me a favor I
have power over you in a certain way if
you're willing to actually do it so I
think that yeah that would be gambling
then right
um I mean you could gamble Halloween
candy if you're going to eat the candy
Andy yeah
I think that that's more traditional
because you know that's that's currency
for kids man yeah well that's why we did
it
and you know somebody would be upset by
the end of the game because they didn't
have any any candy left you know yeah um
you know I'd get upset playing Monopoly
and losing well that's not real Alex
yeah that's interesting uh people get
really upset about that game yeah well
it's it's set up originally to show you
uh the dangers of unchecked capitalism
that's true I forgot about that yeah
it's called the landlords game you know
originally I do want to go back to
something that's a complete tangent
though you mentioned like the Star Trek
next Generation poker game and you could
gamble for things that are not monetary
so there is a one of my favorite stories
by
um the Argentine writer Jorge Louis
borjes is called the lottery in Babylon
and it starts out as a original Lottery
where you know you pay some money and
you take your chances and you might win
some money back or something like that
and the lottery
um people running it make some money on
the side as well and then they start to
include the possibility of losing
something other than your stake like
getting a fine and then people get
really interested because they like the
the danger and then they eventually
start moving to non-monetary benef
benefits or harms and you know because
there's a time when a slave steals a
crimson ticket which is a bad one which
would get him some sort of terrible
punishment and the question is should he
get the terrible punishment because he
stole a ticket or should he get a
terrible punishment because he he
deserves it because of the the actual
payout right and it just said like
blossoms from there and pretty soon like
every aspect of life in this culture
winds up being determined by lotteries
that are done over and over and over
again
and the uh the people love it you know
they can't get enough of it
um but you struggle to when you think
this thing through to imagine a
longboard line how would this actually
work right and I think if you pull at it
too much it probably unravels and it it
doesn't make sense but it's it's an
interesting idea nonetheless and I think
there's all sorts of Mythology around
gambling you know
um
the first one that comes back to this to
me originally is like casting of Watts
while I'm in the Bible and I know
there's
um games that the the ancient Greek and
Roman gods would play
um you know true making bets it's like
oh you know like you know can can um
what Hercules do the the labors or not
yeah yeah
well let's come back to like the
gambling that we were talking about so
yeah there's all sorts of
interesting ethical issues and I think
that something that reveals
the see me side to it let's say the
disingenuousness of gambling
institutions and websites and apps and
lotteries is the very fact that they all
make references deliberately to gambling
addiction and hotlines basically to say
you're not going to have a problem
consumer but just in case you do we've
got you covered you know there's there's
a place to go and we see these gambling
related sites making disclaimers so for
example Sports geek they say it is not
an online gambling operator or a
gambling site of any kind we are simply
here to provide information about sports
betting for entertainment purposes only
if you visit any website we link to from
thesportsgeek.com you have left our site
by visiting our website you confirm you
understand it is possible to lose some
monies when betting on sports or doing
any gambling you cannot hold the sports
geek responsible for already such losses
some links on this website may be
affiliate or referral links and we
receive compensation from them some of
these include but are not limited to
FanDuel and fantasy draft our site is
here to provide entertainment and should
be viewed as that and nothing more so I
think this big claim that gets made over
and over again this is really just
entertainment this is not about making
money this is just to have fun and yet
of course we are generating huge huge
profits there's a bit of a disconnect
there right
yeah and that they know that there's
going to be some people you know that
are genetically predisposed to
um you know be addicted to things be it
like substances or otherwise and there
are going there's going to be a subset
of the population that as gamblers are
um
going to uh user money in very uh unwise
ways to potentially the detriment of
their own health or even the health and
well-being of those people that depend
upon them there yeah if you can't if
you've got kids and you can't make rent
because you bet with the red money then
you and your kids might be out in the
street and that is not a you know uh an
ethical thing to do as a father
um you know father or whatever I think
that the predisposition thing that
you're bringing up is important and we
can talk about genetic and we can also
talk about
you know culture that you grew up in if
you see everybody else around you making
foolish bets and not you know thinking
these things through but saying oh this
is what we do this is how we you know
I've got a system you know we go out and
get our lotto tickets on Fridays or
stuff like that I think you're probably
predisposal predisposed to I don't know
what word I was saying back there uh to
be more vulnerable right
um or if you're like depressed or you've
lost your job or you're you know there's
other things going on maybe that also
makes you more vulnerable to
becoming no longer a customer but but an
exploited Mark and and as I brought up
earlier like they use you know um things
similar to a Skinner box that I um you
know it's got lots of nice stained
lights and uh sorry
digging noises and pretty lights that
are that they've gone through extensive
amount of research to see what
combinations of things get you to keep
on pulling that lever uh or hitting the
button or putting it in the next bed in
um and uh these are inherently
manipulative strategies in order to try
to maintain a person sitting at the
table longer than they would otherwise
yeah so maybe what we have to think
about here is what we could call ethical
incoherence I mean it is a good thing if
they are including
um references to you know you want to
avoid addiction if you find yourself
becoming a problem Gambler here's the
hotline to call that's a good thing
um it would be a good thing to also
um just provide entertainment right and
but those are not compatible with this
as you said very deliberate very
manipulative
way of tapping into people essentially
as as a market you know to squeeze as
much as you want out of them you can't
have it all right so you've got to
decide where you actually come down and
I kind of think that if you're going to
be doing the let's soak them for as much
as we possibly can that's going to be
the priority you know the other stuff is
just kind of window dressing
right and we spoke about it this all
maybe a year ago but the
um that there's another aspect of
asymmetric knowledge problems here oh
right yeah you got to explain for our
for our listeners what that is
um so a asymmetrical knowledge problem
is when you go into a transaction where
one person has a lot more information
about like the true value or like
potentially the market value of a thing
and the other person doesn't and so they
um the person that has more information
can
um use this to obfuscate the the true
value of a thing and sell them something
that they they don't know and so
um that that would be a bad deal so this
comes from the world of Economics yeah
um and so in this case we have the house
that actually knows the probabilities of
these things and unless you have to
unless you dig down into it and be a
very well-informed Gambler
um then you are not uh don't have the
full pick picture of what you're
actually getting into and so as you're
saying if it's part of your like just
the cultures look everyone gambles
you're not usually thinking about this
in a really fundamental way unless
you're um you know uh
Pascal or something well or if you're a
professional Gambler and this is where
it gets really interesting right
um I actually had a colleague who was
um a she was a philosophy Professor but
she was also a professional Gambler she
played poker and she would come here to
Milwaukee and she was you know she'd get
all the perks and stuff like that and as
you were talking about that I was
thinking Okay so
you can acquire
pretty good knowledge about a particular
game of chance like you know in
blackjack you can in fact count cards
it's not a legal they'll kick you out if
they catch you doing it but it's you
know it's a technique that people do and
it's it's learnable by I would say the
average person but it's only applied to
that one game right and similarly with
poker so you know she would go off on
vacations all of her vacations were
basically opportunities to gamble and
she would usually come back having made
money because she was good at that
particular thing now when we get to
lotteries
there's no way uh to to game it I mean I
actually had a a girlfriend whose dad
was convinced that he had a system and
this is back when I was a mathematics
major and I was like well that sounds
really interesting can you show me how
it works and he gets out these notebooks
and he'd written down the Powerball
numbers
every single night he'd watch it
religiously right and then I asked him
well what do you do with all these
numbers and he said well what I do is I
look for the ones that haven't come up
yet and we're going to talk about that
in a bit right and I'd be like it's six
digits how in the hell could you
possibly have any idea you're not
entering it into a spreadsheet or
anything right how would you possibly
know and it came down ultimately Tim
well I kind of feel which numbers
haven't come up lately and then I bet
those right and you're like well that is
I mean that's exactly the kind of person
that they they love to see coming
because they think that they actually
understand how these things work and
they they clearly don't and I think with
the lottery there's there's not a lot of
ways to easily game it and then same
thing with like sports as you were
pointing out I think a lot of people
think they know more about sports teams
and how things work then they actually
could possibly do I mean there
one person could yeah I mean okay so
maybe like Joe Pereira the rule guy from
the NFL who's doing football all the
time and maybe he could right but he'd
be he wouldn't be allowed to that's
where that's where Pete Rose got himself
in so much trouble he was a major league
baseball player with the Reds and he
gambled on his own face
well yeah that's like well now you're
gonna throw the game or not you know
that's the whole many stories about link
Hill uh What fighters are throwing their
own are betting against themselves and
then throwing the match yeah yeah well
there and there was that uh world series
Scandal way way back oh yeah the White
Sox yeah except they were called the
black socks because in infamy right yes
um the uh what Shoeless Joe Jackson and
the the
others yeah but so you know it it really
is for most of these opportunities to
gamble it's really impossible to not be
at a major disadvantage
when you're playing right right and and
so that's why it's saying like you know
you you could be Joe Pereira
um but if you got like 50 guys uh
running numbers and they're like I am
only looking at first down percentages
um and that's my only thing I'm looking
at yeah for the entirety of the the
thing and I got like sheets and sheets
and seats of this over like the last 30
years uh at their fingertips it's going
to be really hard to beat that guy
because he's got so much more
information than any individual probably
does yeah true
so this sports betting is not going to
be you know a thousand Joe pereiras
showing up it's going to be all sorts of
people parking their car for 20 minutes
going in making their bets and probably
uh contributing to the the wealth for
the stockholders of the corporation
right so so this is um
going back to a kind of an idea of
um we kind of talked about individual
ethics but now maybe societal ethics is
something that we can like dig into like
of
we have here you know what uh putting in
the state lotto is and
um that it was originally put forward
for
um trying to get money for schools at
least that was the argument that they
made yeah yeah right and not just in
Wisconsin all all across the nation as
these were being rolled out it was this
is gonna like this is going to fund
education and it's going to be so good
think about the children who are going
to benefit from this
um but then what was the the outcome
like well then they just reduce the
education budget at the state level yeah
there's two things that happen there
there is that it becomes sort of like
police uh cities where the the uh the
budgeting becomes dependent on the
police writing tickets it's not not a
good way to do things right it's a
perverse incentive yeah so there's that
going on and then you also have
um people start tweaking the stuff it's
starts getting used for other stuff like
right now in Wisconsin
um the lottery is being used for
um property tax relief
so that's very different than education
I mean they're kind of that just turns
it into a regressive tax right because
you're like hey who's going to pay the
most uh property taxes people that have
the largest properties which are mostly
the richest people yeah yeah who plays
the lottery the most the people are poor
and so you just like siphoning money
from the poor to the rich in that regard
that's right and I'll I'll tell a story
that I think I may have told you before
but I'm sure our listeners haven't heard
I I worked at a gas station in Sheboygan
Falls when I was just out of college and
I wasn't quite sure what I wanted to do
and I was working second shift and they
you know like every other gas station
sold lottery tickets and there were the
scratch-offs and then there were the
um was it pick three or pick four and
then there's the Powerball right and so
people would come in and they'd have
their numbers and they'd have their
printouts and stuff like that and you'd
have to you know process that for them
and charge them and it was interesting
too because back then you couldn't pay
for any lottery tickets with credit
cards It could only be cash or check
because I think they realized already
that it was too easy to to go into debt
but then with the scratch-offs I saw all
sorts of just crazy irrationality people
would come in and they would be like uh
what tickets are hitting and I'd be like
I don't know I mean I'm running a gas
station here I'm not like just doing uh
scratch off tickets and so then if you
knew you'd be winning right exactly and
they'd ask us if it was like you know
asking the person at the bait shop you
know where are they biting today what
are they biting on right and don't you
understand that this is supposed to be
random you know and clearly they they
did they thought like I had an in
somehow as this lowly uh clerk working
behind the counter some of them would
accuse me of holding on to the good
tickets for my friends and I'd be like
how the hell would I know what the good
tickets are and then the saddest thing
that I ever saw was there was a guy who
would come in every Friday night and he
would put 50 bucks down on the counter
and he'd want fifty dollars worth of
scratch offs and they were usually two
dollar scratch offs that he was doing so
25 scratch offs then he'd go off in the
you know near like the coffee machine
and get a coin out and start scratching
them off and and then he'd you know he'd
win like maybe 25 bucks or so and he'd
come back and you can turn in lottery
tickets for buying more lottery tickets
and that's exactly what the guy would do
and I'd be like are you sure you don't
want to take your winnings and he'd be
like no uh I I know I'm gonna hit the
big one soon and so he'd take that 20 no
that you know 25 dollars worth of
lottery tickets and he'd scratch them
off and then he'd come back you know and
he'd won like 12 or 13 bucks and I would
see him go back and forth you know like
four or five times just losing money
every single time and looking you know
Saturn Saturn sadder uh he'd be real
excited while he's scratching him off
and then he'd be sad coming back up to
to me and eventually it'd be all gone
you know the only time I ever saw him
win he got a 200 payoff
and I was so disgusted with the whole
thing by then he wanted to give me a
five dollar tip and I wouldn't take it
because I was like this is this is awful
you know
um but that I I saw him come in you know
weekend after weekend after weekend
after weekend he certainly put in way
more than 200 bucks to to win that 200
bucks right
and so there's a question of you know as
a a social good is this thing a social
good or is this overall social judgment
there are definitely people that have
this issue
um because they're succumbing either to
um you know addiction or to just a
fundamental misunderstanding of like
something along the lines of one of the
uh cognitive uh
by the consistent biases of like the
gambler's fallacy yeah so there's one
named specifically after gamblers I
should tell you something right
so the gambler's fallacy on
is uh the idea that the outcomes of the
previous attempt at a random game has
any influence on the next roll or chance
and so
um you you're throwing Dice and like
they're coming up I don't know Snake
Eyes if you're playing craps or whatever
um and if you happen to be able you know
I guess in in craps you want to be able
to roll again but like if you're in a
game or like you're pulling the slot
machine
each individual
um
role is a totally random event that it
has zero influence is not influenced by
any of the previous or the subsequent uh
polls of that thing so there if you were
um
if you had like a a jar of marbles and
you pull and they're like you know it
starts off 50 50 black and white and he
pull one out and he don't put it back in
um then uh you are changing that you're
changing the odds yeah but almost all of
these
um you're not doing that like the only
one that I'm thinking about is like you
know if you're playing uh 21 or
blackjack
because you're now changing so um but uh
scratch-offs uh and uh slot machines and
a lot of other ones that are pure chance
are set up so that each role is
individual so there are no hot machines
and there are no cold machines and none
no none of these slots are actually due
for anything because none of the
previous uh
chances will have any effect going
forward yeah I mean in sports betting
you could like talk about okay this team
is on a streak but I mean they say any
Any Given Sunday right that couldn't
change and we've seen that happen so
many times
teams that were like oh they're they're
really you know just plowing away and
then they lose to some team that's no
good you know right
um and then
um
there's there's other uh biases here's
like confirmation biases
um that paying attention to highlighting
what one will like to be the case and
ignoring what goes against that this is
you know
um kind of like counting the misses and
ignoring the counting the hits and
ignoring the misses yeah
um yeah if you asked somebody was it a
good night gambling and then they talk
about what they won but you're like well
how much did you pay to win that oh well
they worry about that you know I I I'm
willing to lose a certain amount again
no what's the actual sum you know are
you positive are you negative right
that's that's the uh the key right there
um so I guess we talked a little bit
about societal issues like if you're uh
if you're losing is going to negatively
affect you know someone that is
dependent upon you
um but we've got a couple other ones
here
um
any of them that you wanted to go about
sure well I mean the effects of becoming
an addict or a problem Gambler are they
you could think of them as ripples that
extend out quite far so you know the
primary consequences are to the person
themselves and a lot of people they you
know they really ruin their not just
their finances but their lives through
gambling it impacts their relationships
with other people
um you know makes them unable to do the
sorts of things that they would want to
do like pay off loans or buy a house or
even you know buy the car that they want
or in some cases put you know food on
the table a lot of people do become
addicted and they're they're placed in
situations where there's fewer limits
and protection these days it seems as if
here in the United States we have been
framing it in terms of like let's let
everybody have a good time and have fun
but we're we're not protecting
vulnerable people and we're particularly
not protecting the children who are
seeing this and then we'll be like well
Mom and Dad do this I see ads for it
when I'm watching the game with them why
shouldn't I do this this sort of thing
and what we do know and there's a lot of
studies out there on this and we'll link
to some of these
it does you know when you have a
gambling entity you do see rises in
violent crime and suicide and divorce
and bankruptcy so it's not always a net
gain to get these sorts of things and
some experts are seeing uh you know
looming potential social crises in the
banking sector and the housing markets
and the health care industry all of
these are affected significantly by uh
people's finances and by gambling and I
I think we could also say that it's
corrupting the sports organizations and
the individuals themselves you know when
we have these celebrities who are
Hawking yeah just make a bet it's so
much fun and they're like you know you
see them there with all their buddies
and stuff like that throwing a football
around
that's corrosive to a person's character
and it's also not good for our
governments
um they are getting a lot of income out
of this it's it's easy to become
dependent themselves and compliant and
corrupted and what are they doing there
they're selling out their own citizens I
I saw I know this sounds a little
extreme but I think maybe it's warranted
to say this
um they are sacrificing and exploiting
their own citizens that they're supposed
to be protecting
for the interests of
these gambling entities and the other
you know the other parts of the house as
we were calling it earlier right the the
larger group and we do at least have
some moratoria we don't allow you know
miners to gamble
um theoretically theoretically but you
know a lot all this advertisement is
being seen by this you know if you have
like big sports stars kids look up to
sports stars and they're saying this is
good you should be doing that then it
definitely increases their potential
desire to actually do these things and
we already have an issue on where miners
are actually basically gambling nowadays
a lot of video games including
specifically like um
uh EA's FIFA which is you know the one
of the largest games in the world it's
you know soccer league it's it's like
you know
um the the Madden football games but for
soccer
and a lot of other games have these
things are loot boxes and so they're a
uh an item that a player will attain
from playing the game but they can't
open them unless you have a key you have
to physically actually buy the key which
is also fraught because you can't buy it
with just money you have to buy a
currency and then buy that and so now
you're like removing a step away from
actually dealing with bunnies like money
is now coins and then coin goes to there
and so use every time that you step away
from it you're not thinking like what am
I actually paying for
um and then you hit the use the key to
open the loot box and
um it's a random item that arises and so
on this has gotten so bad and these
companies have
um
breakdown so many hundreds and millions
of dollars from this and other you know
kind of predatory micro transactions
um that are mostly directed towards
children uh yeah and unregulated
essentially right right
um except for it's now become illegal in
Hawaii the United States and
um Belgium in the EU but there are 18
more EU countries that are looking to do
the same because they see it it's like
oh yeah this is a major problem
well and that demonstrates something
that goes far beyond this in scope but
the difference between the EU and the
USA you know in the USA we claim to care
about everybody and and you know protect
citizens and especially protect children
but you can look and say well that's not
actually happening and they're not being
protected from and we can always look
and say well who's actually making money
you know that old thing of kui Bono
who's who's uh deriving some sort of
profit or good from from a transaction I
think could be a helpful guideline here
in the EU they have a uh you know I'm
not saying it's a Utopia or something
like that but they at least have more
capacity to do what's good for their
their citizens you know yeah
um well we're getting close to the end
so do you think uh is there any
particular thing that you want to wrap
up with or do you want to just jump into
our traditional ending quote Yeah so
today we leave you the words of George
Bernard Shaw in gambling
the many must lose in order that the few
may win
please
foreign
[Music]